katharine mcphee and 3d there are
benefits to seeing this home we are
going up to Lake Crosby to Sarah asked
you are you ready for the lake
room for one more yeah totally cool boy
oh you guys have fun back there quite uh
what we had in mind
shark Night 3d is directed by the
director of the final destination a
terrible awful horrible movie yes final
destination for I like scary movies my
parents kind of always introduced Maori
movies that show my jaws when I was like
six
my mom and I used to watch the x-files
you know scary movies have always been
kind of thing for my family I like him
and I'm a little bit easier on them than
the average movie reviewer would be this
film is about a group of teenagers they
decided to go party on some lake and
stay there for like a weekend or
whatever and all of a sudden there are
sharks in this lake and you know it's a
saltwater lake how do sharks get there
you want to hit that home your secret's
safe with me man
and you know the filmmakers say a lot of
different things for where the Sharks
could be they're like oh maybe a
hurricane like washed it up into the
lake and everything I lay its dumb stop
right there you commenter somebody's
about the lights start coming you know
hurricanes actually always bring sharks
to saltwater it happens quite often this
is my PhD right yeah so the teenagers
are funding op against the sharks and
there's these crazy - Hicks that are
there that somehow seem to be involved
with something but we don't really know
and you know what those Hicks remind me
of they remind me of the way these Hicks
come in I mean it's just like they might
as well just walk in there like obi-wan
I just wanted a fun movie that knew it
was dumb and for the most part I got
that later in the movie it seemed like
it try to get really serious you got in
realizing you're making a movie like
this that you can't pull that off it's
just it's so corny you know and you just
gotta go with it
I don't know how they got in here maybe
someone put them there
and a lot of people are complaining Oh
pg-13 what did he do jaws is PG and yes
jaws would never be PG nowadays now they
have a pg-13 rating but it works when
you see somebody to kind of get pulled
under the water it's like oh crap
because it keeps the scariness there
there are some messed up kills later
though for you people who have to see
that kind of stuff for the most part I
didn't really have a problem with the
pg-13 rating a lot of people are saying
like why don't the teenagers just stay
out of the water that solves everything
and I was thinking that too but the film
is able to convincingly give reasons for
why they might be in the water and it
works for the most part I mean it
doesn't it doesn't seem like dumb
there's a few times when I was like
seriously you're going in the water
right now
basically my big issue with the film was
just that it tried to be a little more
serious towards the latter half and also
my other huge issue is that I won't
spoil anything but once the the reason
the Sharks are there is revealed
it's so stupid it is just so silly and
unbelievably dumb that I was like you
gotta be kidding me man you just gotta
be kidding me I I would have gone with
the hurricane washing the sharks into
the lake seriously that would have been
a lot more fun than what what actually
happens some of the actors were trying
some of them were not Wow but some
really did a good job for what they had
the material they had I mean you there
they know what they're in the best part
of this movie I would say is actually
the 3d I thought the 3d was very good I
knew when I was expecting walking this
movie so I wasn't like disappointed or
anything like I mean what'd you go to
shark Night 3d what are you expecting
honestly
so shark eye is a silly and dumb horror
movie that got way too serious in the
end and have stupid character
motivations that are just unnecessary
but what are you really expecting I'm
going to give a shark Knight a C+
seriously everyone just go watch the
debt please just skip these two movies
and watch the dead or watch jaws yeah
that's a good idea so if you liked my
review you can subscribe to my channel
and get stuck man hi